he is the number four heavyweight in the
UFC we flew him all the way from Denver
Colorado it's Curtis blades on this
week's food truck Diaries and I'm
feeding them pastels from Brazil let's
go
[Music]
Curtis blades what's up big dog happy to
be here man yeah appreciate you doing
this man it's been I've won John here
for a hot second we have a mutual friend
he's your coach one of my best friends
Cody Donovan known that kid forever he's
literally a brother of mine and you're
you're rocking uh are you letting
everybody know you're from Chicago you
gotta roof Chicago Harley home always
repping yep I mean they're not great
this year but at least Fields he's moved
to be a good pick yeah you guys have
nobody else no you have Mr Justin Fields
this is where it all starts though yeah
true you got the the key kind of area in
football you have the quarterback now
you gotta build the rest of the team
it's always next year yeah that's that's
I feel like this Chicago Bears motto
yeah we always got next it's always next
yeah so so but this isn't about the
Chicago Bears as much as we like the
Bears yeah for you it's uh it's been
kind of a it has to be frustrating for
you because the division especially the
heavier division has been held up and I
will make this clear and Kirsten Thomas
this is coming from his head coach I've
talked to people in the business
one of the reasons you can't get a fight
too this has to be frustrating because
you're in the Ultimate Fighting
Championship a lot of these guys I'm not
going to say their names the guys ranked
ahead of you turn down the fight yeah
they want a striker they don't want to
deal with this that's what it is Juco
National Championship wrestler you know
who's only getting better they they want
to strike her they want you know they
don't want to deal with your dynamic
they want to fight where they can they
don't have to worry about the added and
charitable but that's I can say this is
MMA I think that should be a part of I
think everyone should know how to
wrestle but I'm the only one who does it
apparently in this division besides
asking I'll be his injured yeah I'm the
only one that knows how and I'm gonna
use it and I people get angry at me for
using my wrestling hilarious I hope you
don't listen to that I don't I know I
want to break the record I want to break
the gsps I think he's got 90. I want to
break his record do you know what you're
at I'm at 63. oh you can break it yeah
oh yeah especially with these guys
coming up exactly especially you know
because the one guy that that does have
wrestling Hugh you can potentially faces
Jones he's another National Champion
Juco guy obviously he has really good
wrestling yeah so he'd be the only
opponent that could get next that would
you know go toe-to-toe with you in the
wrestling Department we would see I
think the wait when you you wrestle at
just the difference between 215 or
197 compared to heavyweight it's
different when you're on the bottom when
he's underneath me which I do plan on
him being underneath me yeah he's gonna
he's gonna use a lot more energy than
what he's used to using I think that'll
be the biggest actor yeah so if you had
a a crystal ball or you if Dana calls
you up when you leave this interview
goes hey it's all it's all food truck
it's my favorite show
um we'll let you pick uh Jones that's
the money that's the name that's the
that's when you build your luggage
outfit I beat him all the doors are open
all the sponsorships all that stuff like
that's the name and then you also you
know people forget about it you know and
even not you know I didn't mention them
here but Stipe is still number two in
the world Stevie's right there I forget
about him also he's not very he's not
active
exactly it's not very active he doesn't
doesn't remind people that he wants to
fight he seems like right now he's all
right we're just being on the sidelines
that's all right he deserved that he's
earned that but yeah when the best to
ever do it yeah but I mean if you're not
gonna fight I think instead of me having
to slide down the rankings he should
have correct yeah no I agree with that
because you know you want to be active
and obviously Stipe from what I heard
the the hold up with the Steve A Jones
thing was a Stipe issue he's like oh
just not ready or I know he's put on
size and wanted more time or whatever
but you know stupid is not afraid of
anybody but that could be another you
know pretty big star you could fall on
from a Cleveland Feller that's not bad
fight's not a bad gig over honestly any
of them Jones would be the best
that's great also yes Steve is great
even gone anyone just someone ranked
higher than me I don't want another guy
a darkest yep or offense but that
doesn't help move the needle no not at
all so it's for your legacy too yeah and
uh when you look at the matchup with
Jones you have advantages where you
think
size power explosiveness he's not the
most explosive guy he's very creative
with the Striking but very creative does
everything very well explosion he does
everything well I think he's more
well-rounded but the wrestling the size
explosion and uh Power I think jab for
jab we both connect he'll go backwards I
won't yeah I think for John and I I
think he's the best ever do it and I
used to train with John and you know
I've seen with other heavyweight team
he's a monster you know he's used to
those big bodies but uh for John if you
look at his previous you know few fights
and I don't know if it's uh motivational
thing or whatever you'll see him get hit
you know the Donald Gray's fight the
Santos fight you see him take some hits
that heavy weight you can't do that no
yes this is just totally different
different games yeah I think you realize
that but it's also be interesting to see
him because we've never seen him at this
size like you know you see these videos
you're going to have the conditioning to
bounce the way he likes to bounce yeah
those are all factors that I think about
I know he thinks about but I don't think
fans and oddsmakers and all that on the
day factor that into it yeah no I get
that yeah I think it would be just I
mean by far your biggest fight because
look at the lay of the land Steve may be
a big fight Steve's doing a big fight
he's fighting yeah I hope I hope that
happens but again I can't emphasize
enough a lot of the reasons why you're
not getting fights a lot of guys are
turning these fights down it's not draft
can wrestle I want them you gotta quit
showing off that dump blast double all
the guys I actually haven't well the
other thing you didn't even use it now
here's the other thing you'll fall in
love with striking too because you're
getting better at striking and you can
tell you striking you're getting way
more comes on feet but I'm still Cody 45
to my remind him where he comes from
dude [__] the noise take these [__]
down out they can't take you down I want
the record yes the only way to get the
record I need to average like five to
take down the fight and at this rate I'm
only fighting twice a year I'm gonna
have to average yeah if I yeah yeah I
plan on I think you can do it well
you're heavyweight so we don't have to
how much you weigh right now to 80. are
you 280
yeah yeah that makes sense yeah I mean
you're not small no but yeah it's not
like I'm not one of those guys dancing
the legs that's and that's why you have
that power double well let me increase
that power double uh and feed you some
food I see some Brazilian um food so
yeah
[Music]
how you guys doing yes
good man thanks for doing this
yeah no problem man well 30 South
Brazilian fast food here uh you guys
call them uh pastel pastels
pastel because uh Empanada in the
Mexican culture right
similar or no
I'm saying but this a lot of differences
uh vacant right yeah and uh but still
it's fried oh nice deep fried Yeah
Dough it's a little bigger also and the
dough is more like a wonton oh nice that
sounds nice yeah because I opened out
it's kind of small right yeah it's more
like appetizers
yeah yeah
oh looking forward to it man yeah what
uh what do you guys recommend well
beefing cheesy chicken
iguana first and second yeah uh mushroom
for the vegan people even if not vegan
it's pretty good I don't think you're
vegan no no I'm gonna go with the beef
that is cheese and I'll do the chicken
and cheese and then do you guys have the
guava and cheese yeah it's like a guava
I love it yeah yeah
a little spicy with together to me it's
perfect I'm in yeah it's just for him
yeah so yeah so one beef and cheese one
chicken and cheese then one guava and
cheese
thank you so much appreciate you guys
who are you Brazilian yeah oh nice I'm
not well yeah that's it nothing else I
like country see ya all right
now I'm on my way
all right my man let's dig into these uh
Brazilian Empanadas To Come pastels but
you know
did it you said it's like a
we say it's like a uh a Wong Tong show
it does look nicer it smells good the
bread is uh squishy
oh yeah
I can eat this yeah it's nice
crazy little hot sauce we have hot sauce
if you want something we got that trough
hot sauce then we got Dustin
hot sauce too you drop a little energy
drink in there I think think stick
um
Buffy if you said you're walking around
280 now when you get in Camp do you have
to cut whatever it's not really a cut it
just happens it's just uh you just get
you lose like the 15 pounds yeah once
you start trading higher cardio I
usually get in the Octagon like 255 58
oh damn yeah it it's all water weight it
comes off you have to watch what you eat
during camp or no like you won't eat
yeah no I won't eat this uh a little bit
I I get meals made like the last four
weeks but before that my girl makes me
food that's cool eat at home I just I
don't eat a lot I eat like once a day
this is it this is it yeah I've done
that not by choice just because my
schedule but uh I feel finding once a
day yeah a lot of people do though I
think that's like the caveman thing I
think it's called enter
intermittent fasting intermittent
fasting yep that's when yeah you usually
wait because you don't eat to win like
why two o'clock in the afternoon
but then the week of the I my coaches
won't let me do that because they know
it's bad so I'll eat
three small meals a day but every other
day is just I mean your coach Cody
Donovan his coaches Cody and Vinnie
how's it going okay I came up with
Vinnie too yeah I didn't know him as a
coach just fighter oh well he's a great
coach yeah really good guy
um
loved any they need to chill out on you
not eating once a day I mean if that's
what your body's used to if you're
always training like I was used to the
week of the fighting three times like
doesn't make sense I have to like make
myself eat an apple at like 8 A.M like I
don't want this but they're watching me
Let Him Live his life for God's sakes
obviously it's working how dare you but
uh yeah they better I think that's both
of them let's take a little break from
chatting with one of my faves Curtis
blade such a Savage hope you guys are
enjoying this show this new year you've
got goals and factors here to help you
achieve each and every single goal fuel
up fast with ready to eat nutritious
meals delivered straight to your door
leaving you time and energy to tackle
everything on your to-do list whatever
it is you got kids you don't have time
to cook your own meals achieve and
maintain your 2023 goals with Factor get
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit and start saving time right now
start eating well and living your best
year yet too busy to cook cool say less
with facto skip the trip to the grocery
store and Skip The Chopping prepping
cleaning it got it all for you factors
fresh never frozen meals are radiant
just two freaking minutes so all you
have to do is heat it up enjoy and
you're getting the shred City no matter
what your lifestyle is Factor has
delicious flavored packed meals to help
you live it to the fullest with keto
calories smart vegan veggie and Protein
Plus options on the menu each single
week prepared by chefs approved by
dietitians each meal has all of the
ingredients you need to feel satisfied
all day long all right so you want to
cut back and take out get Factor instead
not only is Factor cheaper than take out
but meals are ready and faster than the
restaurant delivery in just two freaking
minutes they get all vegan veggie we got
you covered man get factor and enjoy
clean eating without the hassle simply
choose your meals enjoy fresh flavored
packed meals delivered straight to your
door ready in just two minutes no prep
no mess that's coach shop 50 at
factormeals.com shop 50 to get 50 off
your first box this episode of food
truck Diaries is also brought to you by
my fave my absolute fave you're talking
about Alpha Brain and guess what they
make the best nootropic on the freaking
planet that's right they've sold over a
million freaking bottles of Alpha Brain
I like the Alpha Brain Black Label
people because it's highly concentrated
but if you're not ready to jump into
them deep Waters with nootropics try
just the regular Alpha Brain from on it
it's the ultimate way to get into that
flow State again they sold over one
million bottles Alpha Brain promotes
cognitive function including memory
mental speed and focus can help you
remember names who doesn't need help
remembering names who remembers names
these days zero in on complex tasks and
think more clearly under stress my boy
Joe Rogan says it helps them feel
good and form better sentences when he's
talking be more like Joe all right Alpha
Brain contains amino acids and plant
compounds that promotes the brain's
release of alpha waves which are
associated with greater creativity and
productivity all right at the same time
as Sports neurotransmitters chemicals
that relay information in and from the
brain if coughing energy drinks make you
all jittery you can rest easy knowing
that Alpha Brain is caffeine free no
Jitters just the good stuff but for any
reason if you don't love Alpha Brain you
can get your money back just give them
two weeks if at that point you don't
feel like Alpha Brain is a fit for you
which is crazy just tell them why and
they will refund your money on the spot
no return necessary all you got to do is
save 10 off your order by going to
audit.com
all right or swing by your local Walmart
and pick some up today but let's not go
to Walmart let's go to audit.com job
help your boy out save temps off the
best nootropic on the planet Alpha Brain
we got you on it.com job now let's get
back to the program
there's a lot of that because I know you
get nervous oh yeah you're really you're
nervous wreck I'm a head case yeah the
Narrows are crazy I'm the opposite I
know a lot of guys like
they they don't put the time and energy
into the camp in their life
it's all right with them agree but me I
put in a lot more working effort into it
than the night of the fight of Mike did
I do enough did I run those Sprints that
one day correct eight weeks ago did I do
them hard enough yep just gets in my
head but then too you go out there you
touch gloves and it goes away it goes
well yeah it's just the worst part is
just getting into the hotel like the the
day of the fight the worst man I
actually enjoyed how they did it during
uh covet you get there like an hour
before the fight oh I love that that'd
be great because yeah I mean I fought in
Brazil I was in there six hours before
the fight because they said just like
bad but it was some weird thing going on
but there's been fights if you're on the
main card you know either there's fights
already happening to the the arena your
Locker Room's been used so it's like
this weird like the energy fight smell
like yeah almost you know you can tell
somebody's hopes and dreams were
shattered in there then you gotta like
you're in like your suit or your
clothing like change it's just awkward I
don't like it
the first time I really had a long long
wait was my first Main Event
um during the Santos fight okay is that
a fight night yeah five rounds too well
thankfully it only went for a round and
a half but yeah scheduled for five yeah
and um yeah that was my first time
having a waiting a back room for like
over four hours I was just I'm just
chilling yeah when you're mad I think
you should do like we warmed up once I
cooled down read a book let's do some
music I warmed up again I just ran out
of ideas yeah I think you guys are
trying to like occupy themselves fight
yeah so I mean I saw Dave Herman he'd
play his game boy he's playing like trip
old school
yeah some guy with a book before I'm
like you know damn well you're not
focused on that book it was like Harry
Potter yeah I had it up for like five
minutes I can't read this there's no way
I remember we were fighting uh MGM Grand
and Shane Collins with Brock Lesnar I
was fighting Chris toucher and obviously
changed the main event the day of the
fight my nerves are going through the
roof of course Chris Usher was like 21
on wrestler All-America North Dakota
State and I was like I don't know if he
gets me down well I'm just that's just
going through your head I I was always I
was always by myself and I was like man
I need to be around someone these
thoughts aren't good so I grew up when
Shane he had like this week because
fighting Brock Lesnar I'd go on there at
least her bones there and Cody's
everyone's in the room and it's packed
I'm like yeah this is great it's easy to
hang out yeah because you're just
talking about whatever [__] with the
boys and then James just on staring out
the window he's just he's like shop come
over here I'm like ghost be good for me
I go over there and he's just staring at
everyone like at the pool party having
fun and he looks at me goes what the
[__] are we doing what I know no no I
came up here I thought you're gonna help
he's like I need an inspiration we gotta
stop doing this I was like you know what
I'm gonna go back to my room I'd rather
go back to my room and discuss this with
you so I was like this is not helping
dude yeah you and Shane would have been
great training Partners oh he was at um
Muscle Farm when I first got out there
back in 2016 he was there for like a
week really disappeared that was big
right his hands are huge massive
and yeah that's what Cody told me
your coach and again Cody's a really
close friend of mine he's your head
coach
um
yeah yeah so he's your equal yeah so but
Cody knows you well and he was just like
dude I can't emphasize enough like what
you see inside the octagon it's not even
remotely and he's like you think how
good he is in lockdown he goes what I'm
telling you got to come watch him train
dude he's like I'm a lot more destroys
people she's like what's that inspiring
once that Curtis blades enters the
acting or something undefeated he's
thinking he's just warming out man the
confidence that's
I used it earlier um it's growing like
when my uh my strike I I don't feel that
timer in my head like okay it's been a
minute now you haven't gotten the
takedown what's going on yeah yeah it
used to be like that that's how I ran in
for that
um
need for georginio yeah
I had this timeline okay it's middle
last round you should shoot
unfortunately like a good shot yeah of
course it he read it into a flying knee
painfully you still won but mistakes
like that I'm getting past that stuff
yeah not just with the experience a
little more comfortable on the feet and
then it's a slow thought through the
races because there's only one there's
really and you know there's been a new
one like there's only one way to get
that experience that's my doing it it
doesn't matter if training like until
you get in there when the lights are on
and you know Dana White's in cage siding
at the coaches there and you got your
Commissions in there you got Joe Rogan
and you know DC and annik like that's
the only way it's the only way and
that's
that's why it's hard that's why like I
like when I see guys that come in into
the UFC like off the bat they already
have the confidence in their hands I'm
like how do they get that so early I've
been on this for a decade now I'm just
not getting it yeah it's very everyone I
mean everyone's at their own pace own
pace I mean
you know sometimes guys can have that
confidence but it doesn't match the
skill set of the way they performed I've
done you know and I think UFC is doing a
way better job than they did when I was
fighting and even a few couple years
they've done better job you look like
sugar Shawn O'Malley you know you got
Patty pimlet they're building them up
this morning yeah because they're
they're stars are so bright and they're
famous most bigger than their talent for
a little Eddie almost almost lost it
this weekend well I thought he did did
you yeah and you know I don't have a
disagreement anyone that says he lost
my only disagreement is when people say
it was a robbery oh I don't agree with
that you leave it up to the judges you
never know I know what's going to happen
dude as a fighter like that's the
mentality of every fighter like and
because that's you know the captain the
[__] chip Dana White Ghost don't leave
up to the judges man that's on you yeah
no no that doesn't work for me though
you don't say like like you just you
can't leave it up to the judges it's
like no I I get that you should be able
to but yeah you can't I know and but
nobody's doing anything to fix that
problem we just all accept I heard about
the open open score that would be dope I
think that would help like if I know I'm
um who rounds in the three rounds you
can go for broke I'm going nuts and the
other guy people are like what a few
stalls that's on me I have to open them
up yeah he knows he's winning
Keegan salt it's on me to open them you
know what the answer is like I I so I
was a fan of open scoring and I was a
fan of knees to the head like imagine if
you take your identity to the Head who's
going to meet you to that like for you
I'll be the one doing it yeah that's
what I'm saying so for a guy like you or
like you know Mark Chev or even when
khabib was fighting and these dagestands
coming in with this heavy wrestling
pedigree in order to get more finishes
you know and kind of more highlights out
of those Grapplers need to give ahead I
had Big John McCartney on bro
talk to him about open score and knees
to the head he will wreck your world
it'd be like Bryce Mitchell it'd be like
Bryce Mitchell going on Rogan talking
about Flat Earth he doesn't get
destroyed oh I tried it with Big John
and he just lit me up and wow and he you
know he created the rules for the UFC
like he wrote the rules oh bro when you
bring up open scoring are you bring up
needs the head or changing the rules
he's just he has his master's degree and
the rules and why it's set like that and
he just it's hard to argue with him and
I was ready to go I think they open this
morning I think
it needs to be discussed but here's the
open score and I'm with you like let's
say Patty knew he was down but again the
judges gave it to him so
you're just it's just gonna delay you
being upset because let's say you really
thought uh to uh uh Gordon won that
fight right
well it doesn't matter the judges on the
cards oh yeah they're still going to
tell you we need to fix the judge we
need them to be higher higher Acumen
well you gotta hire guys like you you
gotta find former fighters who actually
want to do it you know who don't want to
do it absolutely not
but no there's a lot well I'm also you
know one of the outlines that I have so
much else going on but there's a lot of
guys who retire and there's not much
going on so if you get those guys
training properly with the judging and
the criteria they're gonna have a much
better eye for it I would like that I
wouldn't be against it all right because
this model now you know it's based off
the criteria so the general viewer would
understand from boxing the 10-9 I don't
even know the cards are like is it
aggression is it image because sometimes
like you bring here's one uh GSP versus
Hendrix because after Robert Hendricks
won everyone did based off the desk
except for the judges even Saint Pierre
like Jesus Christ he retired after that
he's like [__] this I don't want to do
this yeah but so that's a robbery you
know what I'm saying uh
Vancouver that's a robbery right
um no but that's not but it is though
but Hendrix uh definitely but Hendricks
uh GSP is the big like there's robberies
and that's a big one for me I can
remember that one that's the number one
though oh hey there let's take another
little break what's this you asked oh
this is just everything this is Kratom
from Happy Hippo this is their new Full
Spectrum highly concentrated 60
milligrams of pure
fantastic Kratom it's butterscotch
flavor
it's gonna be intense when you take it
be ready to go it's rocket fuel for your
brain that's right and kratom's the wild
west right now it's like CBD back about
10 years ago we didn't know where to get
it who can trust you can trust my
friends at happy hippo that's right
guess what you know I'll save 20 that's
right go to freaking happyhippo.com
promo code stick23 thick with three C's
t-h-i-c-c-c-23 you save 20 off the best
Kratom on the planet that's Happy Hippo
happyhippo.com promo code is thick23
share that as many times as you want use
as many times you want save time soft
air thing all right Kratom happy hippo
is there a better accommodation get you
some look at this little cute hippo
foreign
breaking news fam my friends at manscape
now sells beard products my beard looks
like trash it looks like the printer ran
out of ink but I'm still here aren't I
but for those of you with that just just
manly 300 Spartan beard man do they have
some products for you they're once again
doing their thing in Men's Grooming with
the brand new beard hedger Pro kit from
a beer trim to a fresh shave the
technology behind the beard hedger Pro
kit allows you to shape your signature
beard just how you want man now you can
finally use manscape products to make
your drapes match your carpet by going
to manscape.com use the promo code shop
for 20 and free shipping the best beard
products on the market just when he
didn't think manscape could get any
better oh but they just specialized in
my Jewels downstairs nope they going
upstairs I'm upstairs as my friend Theo
would say no one likes a weird beard so
say goodbye to all your stubble trouble
with manscape Pro's beard kit all right
it all starts with the beard hedger this
thing is a juggernaut of fixing faces
your girl done like your beard you well
now when this thing gets a hold of it
first off this cordless trimmer has a
freaking supersonic wheel that gives you
20 hair cutting lengths all with one
guard what do you want to do on Philly
fade on your face you wanna you want
that freaking Spartan beard we got you
man it's waterproof you can do it in the
shower but I'd probably do in front of
the mirror just not to mess stuff up the
titanium coated t-blade is tough on the
hair but smooth on your face all right
single stroke they got you bro we don't
need multiple Strokes one stroke hitter
here first there's a beer shampoo and
conditioner all right and guess what
else manscaped has a little beard oil
for you that's right it's essential
piece for your main facial accessory no
one wants a guy who's beard is brittle
and dry and smells like hummus all right
cap off the kit with the beard balm a
Pomade that shapes dude shape your stuff
up I can't do it my Beard's awful but
still I have psoriasis but if you don't
have psoriasis listening to have a beard
get this all right so we get 20 stop and
free shipping with the code shop at
manscape.com that's 20 off with the free
shipping at manscape.com use the code
shop all right manscape beard hedger one
stroke one guard 20 length get your
beard on manscaped
but with Patty because his star is so
bright and he has so much Fame and
because you know he's kind of you know
he had Dana's podcast so he's boys with
him it doesn't people don't root for
that guy no because they feel like it's
undeserved and even you know TJ dilshaw
on food truck before you and he was just
like he was like even when Connor came
on the scene I was fighting I remember
it was like oh [__] that guy you know
like those guys that get all that shiny
like oh [__] this dude like I've been
here five years I don't get paid as much
as he does the action if you have a
British or any anything non-american
yeah it boosts you up automatically
because they want those because we got
enough Americans doing damn thing if I
had a Jamaican accent oh bro bro we're
going Sizzler I know but get your own
shirt I don't have it I don't have an
accent I don't have anything you can't
work out so no
it would smell like the real Jamaicans
they would smell it yeah I think for you
you're uh and I I appreciate and I I
like it you're a cut from the old school
man like meat potatoes it's like you
just want to fight you're not worried
about ripping a promo off you're like me
on Instagram doing a tick tock dance
where the hell it is you know it's part
of the game you know you kind of have to
these days I disagree I I think
especially with your skill set you don't
have to [__] like you just keep winning
and you're already a big enough name
where you just gotta win like not all
where you're at you just gotta win now
if you're a younger guy coming in you
got to win but you know that would be
that kid who has a million followers on
Instagram and if he gets three wins he's
spraying a title shot yeah you're
probably enough to get six yeah it's
just the nature of the business
unfortunately is is fine I get I've been
I built my Instagram up all on my own I
don't hire nobody I well do it all
yourself yeah I've had people ask me
like how come you don't have someone
like it's just Instagram yeah I get why
people hire others to do the instrument
because it helps them with the
sponsorship and getting power shots like
and they don't have to worry about it
either it's like it's one less thing you
have to worry about is a fight yeah it's
stressful especially in today's world
switching the UFC you know it's like
this this other kind of Avenue you know
and you see guys that do well on it
they're getting the title shots and
they're getting these big sponsors but
for you it's just I you know you don't
see my guy too concerned about
endorsements and you just want to win
fights I know and set the record for
takedowns yeah I know I can earn a
living a really good living by just
Friday I know I could probably earn a
really great living if I added all the
extra curriculum stuff and I'm fine with
just having enough yeah to Get Enough by
just elbowing people into the shadow
round yeah yeah you're not a
materialistic person no you see how I
dress yeah I mean if you weren't so
goddamn good at fighting I usually you
tell people not to wear sweats but you
can wear sweat stuff I'm pretty sure
dude I've seen your double leg those
sweats are sick
um well you got the dope Jersey on but
you does your family like are they all
the same like where's this from the
black sheep like
my dad and my brother
um they're both police officers in
Chicago oh wow they like the gym shoes
they like
fancy fancy my dad they like some style
they're way Swagger than me yeah you
dressed us all we were all standing here
you're like what are you doing here you
don't belong yeah I have the height I
have the beard but the fashion sense
enough and they're I mean they're
Chicago cops yeah I mean probably might
be the toughest job in the United States
it's up there it's a tough gig and they
love it for my dad if former he just
retired this year oh good for him keep
on referring to him as an active now
yeah congrats to your pops man I mean to
retire from that especially the past you
know he made a few years tough game the
last five I think he's been he was doing
more of a community outreach stuff like
he was working with being active but not
probably going on the calls not going to
the south side of Chicago my brother
he's
three years he's younger than me he
likes that stuff he's like he's getting
the action oh he likes it I don't like
him he likes it you I mean you there has
to be something in the the Blade's blood
where you guys like to chase this gently
yeah like you being a I mean you're
fighting grown men and steel cage your
underwear and your you know top four in
the world that was my backup
um be cop if the MMA take his cop of all
time you and Ronnie Coleman yeah yeah
right I like Ronnie was a cop and pulled
people over for steroids are you
[__] me dude like sorry man rules
are rules yeah what he must have a
special uniform because my dad's one of
the bigger police officers and I can't
imagine how big is your pops I got an
inch on him he's a little more bigger up
here yeah and you you grew up like when
we talk about Chicago what are we
talking about I grew up on the South
Side I grew up I grew up South Side you
know where um commiskey on the White Sox
playing yeah yeah Bridgeport oh wow like
a mile away from there yeah yeah yeah
and then is the family's still over
there oh yeah yeah um my dad wants to
move because he just retired I'm hoping
to get him to move out to Denver but oh
that'd be probably won't do it he won't
do it he won't like the food he probably
just wants to get out of uh the south
side of him he wants to get away from
the winter that's for you all right
but in regards though I'll give back
your family but in regards to the food
in Denver listen man I'm a torn comedy I
try food everywhere I'm a thick boy I
try food every single place I go I'm
telling the best Barbecues in Denver
Colorado I'm gonna blow your mind right
now and if you and and David yep I've
Been Everywhere Vinnie Cody if he
doesn't make weight on the next fight
don't be mad
um Brother's Barbecue bro
you're not a fan no
have you what other Barbie name Brothers
No knew how Brothers came about and I'm
not associated with them it's just my
favorite barbecue I've been everywhere I
gotta stop hyping them up bro there's
nothing better people don't believe you
they should believe you it's two British
brothers who traveled around America
tasting all the best barbecue spots and
then stealing their ideas and then
making it their own you don't like it oh
you've been in London their food is like
the is it the food is tough their food
is tough there so why would I have a
British guy come here Fair Point Fair
Point Fair Point fair point but I've
been to Memphis I've been in Memphis
I've been have you been like the like
the Pecan Lodge in Dallas is a famous
One never been but I've been to Dallas a
few times
um you got to go there and there's truth
barbecue in Houston
ridiculous I've been to a bunch of spots
in Houston that's where my grandparents
live oh dude always like the little
small little hole in the wall truth is
in the hoods like a newer spot but it's
that I mean there's Brothers Barbecue in
Denver but Denver will say it's good I
won't offend you but for barbecue like
as far as like world renowned truth
barbecue and then with uh it was like M3
barbecue and that's in Houston too
Houston what's good out here for
barbecue now if you thought Denver was
bad uh L.A is really bad we have Baby
Blues in Venice
um outside of that Burbank Handy Market
for our Calabasas companion yeah Burbank
Handy Market we get their food there
barbecue is not California nothing okay
Sushi you like sushi my girl does I
don't well then she would like it out
here we got great restaurants out here
but back to your family also and you
guys know this I mean Mike's from
Chicago uh deep dish ain't [__] right
it's not it's a casserole also quick on
a pizza the casserole it is it's lasagna
casserole yeah it's just not an everyday
thing because it's so heavy it's so
heavy it's a it's a deep casserole it's
so happy it's so heavy
you hate on brothers
this dude but uh so the so uh youngest
brother is it the youngest cop in south
side which is insane you might as well
go fight in Ukraine
um and then your dad retired cop and
then you're one of how many there's five
of us I have an older brother he's also
a police officer in Dallas that's why I
go after that he's a cop in Dallas
they like guns I don't like guns you
don't like guns at all that's one of the
reasons I was like yeah me and being a
police officer that's just not gonna
help I mean they scare you I just like
I've had one before like when I moved
out here it's intense I was like we're
not out here I have to Denver I was up
in the mountains and they gave me I was
a AR-15 yeah yeah I just I don't like
all the power it's so intense yeah I
don't like it and I've always been like
not anti-gun but I've always been
terrified I just I'm not anti but I
should have said Anthony I was at
anti-good I was just scared I've always
been scared of guns I'm more scared and
then until you need one like in LA like
you know there's more guns than our
people your your family in South Side
Chicago like it's just unfortunate what
you have to do it's always been in the
house but I didn't ever had the urge
like oh I want to go touch my dad's gone
no me neither no it never went to my
mind never and you leave it out and we
would never touch it ever yeah good on
you yeah even like if I go to the gun
range like when I'm in Dallas or Houston
like someone invite me to go to the
Grange I'll shoot like I don't know for
10 minutes I'm like I'm good man and
they're like no we have an hour left I'm
like I really lose a bow and arrow I've
always
has like the Click thing and like cam
Hanes I'm out on that level so
uh youngest brother cop data cop oldest
brother cop in Dallas and one of the
other my two youngest sisters I have one
that just graduated from school she's a
teacher out in Indiana and the youngest
one she also graduated from high school
she's she goes to University of Illinois
okay okay family's a little bit as far
as the the boys go I mean you guys are
rough dudes a lot more aggressive than
my sisters yeah but you're so nice yeah
your dad's nice too even though everyone
is so much because I fight in because
I'm from the south side I don't know
from South Side that I would have assume
you're a little more aggressive but you
uh no I mean you know I was a fighter so
everyone assumes I was mean to or
aggressive not anything actually the
opposite I don't see what you have the
confidence like that doesn't come out I
don't want to fight no hell it's like
I'm getting paid for it I don't want to
do it for free no never never but when
you go uh back home to Chicago I'm sure
especially now I mean in Chicago
Muhammad who's blowing up hopefully gets
the title shot shot to Muhammad we'll
see but um so he's doing well and then I
mean you you're clay Guida who's you
know a little longer juice and then you
got you out there doing the damn thing
because not many of us yeah
um yeah when I'm not going home you're
getting more recognition a little bit
hey cops oh you grow up in my time can
he throw a ball out for you I did
actually after the Aleister fight good
yeah they got me they got me they did
okay all right it's about to get pissed
off there man they let you throughout
the pitch yeah I was awful at it I I
warmed up in the back I was just like
this is gonna be terrible better or
worse than uh Conor McGregor's do you
see his oh Mom's better well he risked
it I didn't even risk I just threw a
long oh you went you went to safer yeah
I didn't risk it nope and family was
there like man yeah a lot of people I
don't care I'm not gonna embarrass
myself I'd rather have that than like
the 50 Cent which was like yes
if I try and
whip this and it goes far right or far
left okay yeah so with the family they
support the fighting everything they're
into it originally my dad was highly
against it but I mean UFC yeah I don't
know any dad like hell yeah go fight
grown man still get anywhere for a
living like my dad was like you're a
[__] I'm like my mom's the opposite
though she was like you can do it you
know like Mom's on like you can do it
yeah they give me world Champs thank you
thank you but my dad's into it now
because it's working out the money's
good and I'm good at it so you know I'm
not gonna go up there and like get
abused no hell no no social either style
um
is there any you know once this rides
over is there any desire to be a cop
because that's always there right no
there's no desire to be a cop no like I
said uh me and guns not the best of
friends and uh I'd like to stay involved
with MMA like helping out the Next
Generation yeah maybe bring back some
more of like because MMA it works in
like Cycles like early on wrestling was
dominant
then everyone figured out gear keys and
yeah a little bit Yeah and then it was a
fancy uh touch style kickboxing like the
Dwayne in the world yep now it's back to
the wrestling so who knows 10 15 years
from now who I will be but I'd like to
focus on the rest help out on that yeah
I mean I think yeah wrestling is
starting to definitely come back now
with the daggers days the Russians and
I'm sure you're doing your thing they
got Bo nickel too
um
that is no pump man you're legit he's
legit super legit
um yeah man I I wanted you on the show
for a while when you obviously got
mutual friends I was like man when's he
getting out there like just let us know
he's busy I would have been down yeah
man we'll have to do it again but uh
yeah for you it's you know Francis Jon
Jones that's the that's the plan man I
like your channel yes the waiting game
man but um I hope he you can wear these
I know you're not the biggest fashion
guy your dad appreciate these but
something we do on the show is uh we
give every fighter uh because I'm a
sneaker head so these are from my
friends at suplex in Philly
um so I always tell them to send me a
shoe and I usually help me out my shoes
they're your size okay for the viewers
out there he wears the 16th yeah so the
I didn't have a huge uh list of options
but for being a 16 these are by far the
dopa 16s you're gonna see we're at your
next fight these are made for uh a
person to beat a guy like Francis or
John Jones in the main event
this is it my man so these are for you
from suplex and they're 16. can I open
it up oh yeah we wrapped it like a
Christmas gift Before Christmas early
Christmas and 16 don't come with the top
of the box
Space Jam Jordan's dog I mean one of the
reasons is top I'm not into sneakers
it's hard to get my my size so I know
it's looking easy yeah I appreciate it
bro they're like what size of a 16 like
Jesus but those are by far the dopest
ones man and I have to wear these
because my brothers he wears uh
let me know if you need some kicks but
uh yeah these are these these are the
ones man the 11 and the 11 Jordans the
spaceships and you're from Chicago dude
yeah it just made sense that's a shoe
for a world champion my man I'll go home
next time go to a Bulls game yeah I'll
bust these out I wouldn't recommend
wearing those on the south side of
Chicago but you know your hometown I
don't obviously I've got it my man uh I
can't think enough for coming on I'm
sure we'll do it again good luck I can't
wait for the announcement of your next
fight my man me too but good luck
brother Curtis blades everybody